okay everyone we just got a big preview
for Aquaman with several interesting
photos from the movies showing us the
main characters and the undersea Kingdom
of Atlantis guys let's run through each
of these breakdown the stuff you might
have missed the first image that we saw
shows us Aquaman alone
Arthur curry Jason Momoa as he saves the
submarine as it's being attacked by
pirates sounds like a lot of the action
will come from real-life modern-day
piracy which sounds like it could be the
origin of actually one of the villains
who we'll get to in a bit but next there
is a shot of Arthur curry with mera
played by Amber Heard there on the
surface world they appear to be
exploring some Greek or Roman ruins
presumably some ancient Mediterranean
civilization by the way Dolph Lundgren
is playing Mira's father King Nereus we
haven't seen any shots of him yet but
I'm very excited
next is the shot that everyone is
talking about black manta played by Yaya
Abdul Mateen the second he's looking at
his helmet now director James Wan
promised that black mantas helmet would
look as alien as a does in the comics it
was a joking in the comics the helmet
shoots plasma beams out of the eyes
sound like that will happen because in
the Entertainment Weekly description for
it it's a little raised hell spelling
race RA Y s so I'm sure we'll see that
he's an overseas mercenary he it sounds
like he may be connected with the piracy
organization that Aquaman has to face
like it could be a member of like maybe
Somalian pirates or something like that
it'll be really fun to see that and it
sounds like Black Manta will just be a
supporting villain he's not gonna be the
primary villain we actually see the
primary villain in the next image we're
talking about ocean master from the
comics aka King worm he's played by
Patrick Wilson he's Aquaman's ambitious
half-brother and he hates surface
dwellers and Aquaman of course is
half-human so it kind of creates a
natural tension between them so it looks
like we're gonna be seeing a game of
Thrones style political family drama for
the throne
maybe it's similar to what Black Panther
was a very interesting dynamic there now
the next image shows the next image
shows this director James Wan with
Aquaman and Meera in a sunken ship
location looks very cool they're
speaking with volcko he's played by
Willem Dafoe volcko is a mentor to
Aquaman and once production design just
looks awesome apparently we're gonna see
gladiator arenas
Warriors writing great white sharks
there's just gonna be a lot of cool
things to see what's fascinating to me
is is this moment underwater right now
yeah dancing so yeah I was James Bond
breathing no it's fascinating that like
they're treating it to have like the
weight of the world you know I mean like
you rest on a table underwater right
that next photo we were looking at when
it was the arena with the sharks versus
the seahorses look they're seahorses
they have legs that horse can see seven
statues pointing their their Trident
together there's seven undersea Kingdom
so when we saw that thing unites the
seven that poster with Jason Momoa
wasn't referring to like a seventh
member of the Justice League including
Green Lantern they're referring to the
Seven Kingdoms ago yeah so they're gonna
be getting into all that political drama
it's gonna feel like I assume a lot like
the kingdoms of Wakanda coming together
I know
DC people get pissed off when we try to
root say everything we're not saying DC
ripped this off for a black panther it's
just what you liked about Black Panther
I think you're gonna like yeah I mean
it's the most common war strategy is to
make allies yeah to the last image it
shows Nicole Kidman's character Curry's
mother Queen Atlanta and the image looks
like it's part of maybe a flashback
scene with Arthur as a baby and his
parents when they had to trade him off
from land to sea I loved Nicole Kidman
I'm really glad she's gonna be part of
this movie but if you just look at the
filmmaking strategy here they're filling
the rest of the cast of the really
really great performers like Willem
Dafoe is awesome awful um grin is gonna
be part of this movie I I think this
could be really really fun movie I if it
ends up being a bomb I know you're gonna
clip this out later and be like I feel
like this would be really really fun
movie but I like Jason Momoa in this
part I like his depiction of the
character and I hope this is good
because I I think Aquaman deserves a
movie that's not the Vinnie chase
version and let us know what you hope to
see most from this movie and hopefully a
trailer will be coming soon of course
we'll be doing a full breakdown of it
but based off of these shots and James
wants such a great director I'm really
excited to see but Warner Brothers in
the DCU is able to pull off here and as
always subscribe to new rock stars for
all of our deep dives into the
CEU and all the stuff that you love
thanks everybody